Is it just us?
Hi William, good day. Oh no, no, Ayra is going to be connecting as well.
Help.
All right.
How are you?
I'm good, hope you're well.
I am. I actually have a very, very painful stiff neck at the moment, so I can't move. But yeah, everything else is good. How about you?
That.
Good. Was Ira beating you up over there?
No, no, no, everything's good. Probably too much sleep. Yeah.
Too much sleep, I like it.
Yeah.
Hi, Ira.
Hello. Hi, Will. Hi, Justin. My PC is running slow for some reason. Give me a second. But I heard Justin's telling something, beating him up.
Hello, hello, hello.
Kour.
Yeah, he has a stiff neck. I asked if you were being too rough on him.
Yeah.
I...
No, that's not me. I'm kidding. How are you, Will? How's your week so far?
Yeah.
Never.
I'm good.
It's average, we'll say, we'll say that. How about you?
I just came back from a very long vacation leave and I'm very happy.
I think coming back from vacation is one of the most difficult moments because any momentum that I had is gone. And I start to question, it's like, what is this all about? What is this all for anyway? You know, so I come back from vacation.
I know.
Part of me is exhausted from over-scheduled vacation. The other part is so done with work. I just want to be done forever.
Yeah, I was actually thinking if I'm going to go to work today or not. But then I remember Andy. I remember Andy. She's looking for me.
She remembers my face and that's it. It's enough motivation for her to come to work.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's funny.
Oh, that's kind.
Anyways, thank you everyone for joining our monthly service call. I'll quickly share my screen. Let me know once you see it.
No.
Yep, you got it.
There you go. I hope you can see it.
Not yet?
It's coming through. Yeah, the share started, but it's just still a spinning screen.
Rick.
There you go.
Okay, perfect. So this is going to be for the month of April. Moving on to the agenda items, that's all the same. The check-in highlights, performance analysis, and way forward.
For the...
I'm still not seeing your screen, it's just spinning over here.
Okay, let me try again. Give me a second.
Right.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry about that, William. For me, I rarely see it. How about you, Andy?
PH.
Yeah, I can see it.
And probably just reopen it, Ayra.
Yeah.
Okay, hold on.
Now it's taking a while to load. Let me try another way.
Apologies for the delay.
Let me do it this way. There you go. How about this?
No, it's alright.
Now we're in. Yep.
Okay, perfect. Yep, moving. So this is going to be for the month of April. Agenda items, as mentioned, that's all the same. Check in highlights, performance analysis, and then way forward.
For the check-in slide, this is for you, Will. Can you tell us more about the April performance for Kelly?
Sure, after the.
I guess, yeah, yeah, I was thinking of something else. That's actually in May, but April performance, everything was as normal. Kelly did very well and he just had no issues.
Okay, that's good. So here we can move on. To the highlights, I have two for you. So for the month of April, I saw an increase with his ticket utilization, like the ticket volume that he's been closing. So according to the data that I will present to you,
Yeah.
for the coming slides, there was a 30% increase for the ticket closure trend. And for the resolution rate, it's still 100%. That's very good. It's exceeding the 80% target that we set for him. And then ITBD.
Yep.
We continue to provide you with reliable coverage for your daily operations, so I hope that we're very helpful on that part on your end, Will.
Nope.
Oh yes, absolutely.
Perfect. Moving on to the action tracker, we have three. So regarding the escalation process that we have reviewed previously, I have discussed that with Kelly and he fully understood the escalation process. Did you see any change on this one?
Yeah, he's doing very well now. He's not holding tickets too long. Yep.
Okay, perfect. Thank you for sharing the SOP that you have. That's very helpful.
Sure, yeah.
And for the second tracker, for the second action item, thank you so much for filling out the April CSAT and NPS for Kelly and us, IT by design. So we received a number 10 from you. We really appreciate it.
Sure.
Okay, moving on to performance analysis here. These are the ITBD recommended KPIs. You're aware of this already. So if you want to discuss any items from here, just let me know.
Plus on the utilization trend analysis, so this is the graph that we have for April, we can see that the average utilization for Kelly was 57.8%. That's very good. I compared it from March and there's a bit of an increase like
No, all good.
2 percent. So that's not a bad thing because that's a plus. This positive, there's an increase with the utilization. So the highest I have observed was from week 5. Do you know, like, have you added tasks?
lately for him.
No, our volume is increased a little bit as well. Folks are, I guess, preparing for vacation or coming back for vacation, spring breaks, all kinds of moments like that. We also have had several projects that have gone through. So usually once a project is complete, we will have an uptick
Yeah.
in remnant tasks that we delegate over to the service desk. So that might account for some of that. Now also, we are pushing to get better time tracking. Slowly, we're doing that slowly so that the time tracking is not inflated.
artificially, as we all know very well how easy that is to do. So it might be that he's paying more attention to those conversations in teams he might have with a colleague and then tracking that his time on his ticket as well. So it's probably a little bit from all of those possibilities, yeah.
Okay, that's great news because we're trying to tweak things here in terms of use utilization. So if you need help on my end, Will, just ping me. I'm always available so I can help him out in case he's struggling somewhere. Okay?
Yeah.
Well, the goal is 6 hours on your time sheet every day. And we definitely don't want, you know, anything fabricated, but he and everyone, you know, we have daily huddles that they're not capturing on their time sheet. And that's 15 to 20 minutes every day.
You know, if I call them and speak with them for a few minutes, they're not putting that in as a charge code or time entry, even if it's not related to a specific ticket. So just, you know, I guess reinforce with Kelly that anything he is doing, start to
to examine that and if he has questions how to enter that or what code to put that under, just let me know and we'll let him, we'll show him.
Okay, what I'm hearing is everything should be accounted for. For your meetings, should it be added as an admin time, admin time entry? Okay, I'll double check with it, but did he try, did she try it? Like, have you seen it? Have you seen him sending or putting in admin times for your meeting or not yet?
Yep, yep.
Yep.
TA.
Not yet.
Not yet. Okay. I'll check in with him for you. And I'll let you know if I have questions, but I'll probably have to ask him to direct it to you as you requested.
So, yeah.
Oh, that's, yeah, that's perfect.
Okay, but I'll review it afterwards, okay?
Yeah, and this is a heads up because the initiative has not been rolled out. We're still writing the policies and the procedure SOP for the crew, but I'm trying to get everyone aware what's happening before it's pushed out. So
So we're ahead of the trend there.
Okay, uh, do you want me to hold it?
No, no, go ahead and and and let's start working on them little by little.
Okay.
Okay, perfect. That's settled then. Let's move on to the ticket closure trend and analysis. So this is for April, week one to five. I can see that the tickets that he's been working on increased as what we have discussed earlier. So
The growth that I could see here would be from the previous month, he was able to close 21 tickets per week. And now from April, he was able to close 28.4. So that's very positive. That's great news for us. The total tickets for it can close on.
Yep.
was 142. That's very good. It's reaching the target that we have here. Questions for this, Will?
No.
Okay, thank you. Let's move on to Build It Live. We have an upcoming event that's going to be on August 325. Have you registered yet?
Are you interested?
Are you going? Well, you should.
No, no, I'm definitely not going.
Anybody within your organization?
No.
I think.
Now they're not interested.
That.
Well, we're interested in pretty much anything and everything, but it is, we are in the middle of a major revamping of the entire company, from service to billing to HR, sales, and everything. So we are
Mhm.
The internal team, the management team, leadership team, we are up to our nose in, well, initiatives. So we are locked in for the next 6 to 8 months, extra meetings, and we all know how much fun those are.
And we've got goal tracking and action items and, oh my gosh, so yeah, yeah, we're booked.
I said.
Okay.
Kurt.
If it's okay, Will, I'll be sending you a deck or like a PDF file. It contains like the agenda of the Build It event. You would be able to see there all the speakers and all the types of activities on each day. So you can just browse through it and if ever you would be interested,
Mm.
Hmm.
Yeah, yeah.
We are also offering like a promo code for like a two for one for the payment. So if ever you can just reach out to me and I can connect you as well with Natalie or Ankur. Alright, so I will send you an email right after this call.
Right.
Thank you.
Sure, thanks.
Raceville.
Alrighty, let's move on to the Team GPS. Will, you're already aware of this, but in any case, you're interested in getting to know a full demo for this, we can book it, can book a time with you. Just let us know.
Yep.
For other IT by design services, you're already aware of this as well. So you can browse this. I'll send, I'm always sending you the deck, the copy of the deck, so you can just check it out if ever you need it. And perfect. For the way forward, I have three for you.
Got it.
Yeah.
You got it.
So Kelly is still on track to complete the Apple certification. I know that you have discussed it with him. So hopefully by end of Q2, he will be able to complete it. And then for the upcoming ITBD by Design and Outsource IT holiday, that's going to be on May 25th. We're both out that day, correct?
Yeah.
Yeah, yes.
Okay, perfect. And for the QBR, that's going to be next month, Will. I have scheduled it on June 17th, same time. So are you available, like, in any case, can we invite Mark as well for the QBR?
Yeah, yeah, absolutely. Yep.
Are they training?
You can invite him, but he keeps his own schedule, so I don't know.
Yeah.
And, ohh yeah, um, we're not sure on that, right? OK, but then I'll send the invite.
Right.
Not, not holding my breath for that one.
Okay, moving on to the slide open Q&A. Anybody has questions?
I guess my question is, well, I think this has been talked about and discussed in the past also, that there was a less of an intake of tickets, of workload really. But I think based off of what you mentioned earlier, there are some things that has been ongoing.
so that it can help Ellie with his utilization. I just wanted to know, is it also affecting the utilization of your local guys over there?
The.
Yeah, we don't, we don't, Kelly is one of the team, so we don't treat him any differently. So it's across the board and it's really not, we're not pushing for them to, you know, change anything as far as
Mhm.
the number of tickets they're assigned. We're not onboarding any new clients. Currently, there's always a couple in the pipeline, but nothing major. So really, it's just...
Because we are a...
small MSP. Been around same owner, same leadership for almost 20 years now. It's gotten a little bit boutique-esque, meaning that it's just one big happy family. And, you know, as long as everyone's happy, you know, we treat every ticket like it's urgent.
Mhm.
As soon as a call comes in, as soon as a ticket comes in, we're jumping on it as quickly as we can. Everything, even the most benign requests, you know, we're calling out as soon as we can, and everything and everyone is happy, but you know now, as the owner is looking to...
Okay.
Mhm.
Uh-huh.
toward retirement and being a little less involved, he needs to make sure every and all processes are documented so that he can step back a little bit. And so that's really what we're going through. And part of that is just, you know, top to bottom.
Mmh.
Mm-hmm.
Mhm.
just documenting everything. And so the utilization increase is not so much on the volume increase. It's just making sure we're capturing everything a little more accurately. We've been lax, but it's not been something that mattered. And it's still not going to change much as far as, you know, revenue intake and, you know, percentage that comes from
recurring agreements versus projects versus, you know, product sales, things like that. None of that is really going to change. We're just trying to be able to track it.
better so that the owner can step away and view what's happening from a nice little spreadsheet on the beach somewhere. Totally, you know, feet in the sand, but you know, he's been really, I know, me too, he's been really great to us and so now we're trying to be great to him.
Mhm.
I would love that.
Yeah.
Mhm.
so that he could step back a little bit. I mean, I couldn't imagine doing this for 20 plus years. Almighty. So anyway, not at his level. I mean, as an owner, you know, you know, we're all going to work, you know, I've already been working 20 plus years, but, you know, as an owner, it would be really cool to be able to step back and then maybe
Okay.
Mhm.
And.
Start something else, you know, anyway, but we, yeah, this is really just so that, so that the president and owner founding founder can step back, you know, that's what that's what's driving it.
Hello.
I gotcha. So it's, I'd probably say bottom line of that is it's just the current nature of your business currently. And I think there's going to be more to come. And I think we're doing our best to get that moving for all engineers, I guess, if they get that right, understood.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
PH.
Ohh.
Oh yeah.
No.
probably add that to his belt and understand more and probably soon enough he can do that to himself. I think that's something that we can add on his task so that he has something else to do aside from those tickets that he currently have. Because he's asking also.
Yeah.
You got it, you got it.
Okay, that was my question to follow that. So perfect. Thank you for relaying that.
Yes.
No problem. So yeah, if you needed anything or if you have any type of work for us or for Kelly specifically, then you just holler. I'm just sending a message to Ayra and I and we'll be able to cater that for you. Okay.
You got it. Thank you, Andy.
Thank you very much. Take it away, Ayra.
Mm.
All right. Thank you, Andy. I guess this is the end of my slide, everyone. Thank you so much for joining our monthly service call and see you next month. Thank you. Have a good one. Bye bye.
All right, take care. See you, Justin. Bye bye.
Bye, Will.
Thanks, Will. Bye for now.
You too.